Oh, hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Welcome back!
Oh my gosh, uh, I, like, passed out so fast after...
Well, not after the sponsor stream yesterday, but, like,
after I ate... Did I eat...
Yeah, after I ate... I was like, did I eat dinner?
Yes, after I ate dinner.
After I ate dinner, um... I like...
I was like, I'm going to take a nap.
I'm tired.
I'm, I'm, I'm going to take a nap.
I'm going to set up an alarm.
I, I need you guys to know I, I snoozed on my, on my phone
alarm 10 times, I think.
I, it felt like 10 times to the point where I think, um, I
vaguely remember this, but like, um, One of my parents went
into my room and like just took my phone and shut it off.
Like,
because, you know, every 10 to 15 minutes, it just kept, you
know, ringing.
The alarm just kept ringing because I keep snoozing because
I couldn't wake.
I couldn't properly wake up.
So then like, one of my parents just went into my room.
They had it, and they went into my room and finally shut my
alarm off so that I would never snooze again.
I was so tired.
I'm still tired.
Oh, my God.
Needless to say, I'm going to be taking two rest days in a
row.
So Sunday and Monday, I'm out.
I'm out.
Let me, I need to, where's my, let me open.
a window it always gets like i think like ever since i got
my uh new pc it's like a lot stronger now um um it's a lot
stronger now so like because of that it does generate heat
more often it does generate a lot i feel like it generates a
lot more heat now so like because it's like a super buff pc
but like um so now it's like extra stuffy in my room so i
need like always open the window I have to close my window
at night because I don't want bugs in my room.
Give me a sec.
I don't know.
Okay.
How I open the window is, like, super unconventional
because, like, it's one of those windows where it has two
locks.
So the lock, one of the locks is at the top.
So what I do is that I grab the, so I get the bottom lock.
And then what I do to get the top lock is that I take the
end.
of the blinds and then I just like I use it to poke the I I
take the ends of the blinds and then I pull it up and just
use it as like a pointer stick and just to unlock the lock
and that's how I do it because I'm not tall enough it's a
really tall lock It's really tough.
But yeah, that's how I do it.
Okay, guys, I might actually need coffee.
Give me a second.
I was like, I'm like, oh no, this game, somebody was like,
you should not be playing this game while tired.
And I was like, oh, shit, you're right.
This game is actually hard.
Give me a second.
We'll grab coffee real quick.
All right.
I've got my canned coffee.
My, I'm a canned coffee connoisseur.
oh my gosh okay sorry i thought i put my headphone oh my
gosh why is my headphone so oh no did i accidentally i broke
my headphone in the middle no okay give me a sec all right
it's it's sort of it's not fixed oh no i got to buy new
headphones after i'm a mess right now i i don't
know what headphones this is oh i'm a mess i can't even open
i can't coffee okay now i open it okay you can hear the
strength i'm strong as fuck okay i open it um i'm gonna have
to order new headphones after the stream uh i just started
off a mess
um oh my god but yeah it's been it's been a lot it's been a
lot Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My solution is having an alarm volume so loud I almost get a
panic attack when waking up.
That's the thing.
I do have a very loud alarm.
It's a classic like bam bam bam like that's a sad alarm but
like I've been using that alarm for my whole life like ever
since I got an iPhone um that like my body has trained
itself to like the word that i got used to it like it's not
i'm so fucked on a real fire alarm i i once slept through a
fire alarm i i once slept through a fire alarm luckily it
was like a drill a practice fire alarm like it wasn't a real
fire fire alarm because i'd be really fucked because i live
in a very very i live on like the higher floors um at my
apartment so like I'd be very, very fucked.
I, I, okay, not gonna lie, I'm gonna say, I don't
understand.
I don't know if this is, like, an Asian thing, but, like, I
actually, I honestly, I don't understand.
Oh, so I'm like, I don't know why.
Every time, like, I start stream, my chat dies.
I don't know if it's, like, an OBS thing or whatever.
But it's been, like, if I, like, swap from this scene, my
chat just disappears.
and i don't know if it's like an obs um an obs bug or
whatever but it's happening a lot frequently um but um wait
where was i on topic uh no oh yeah okay i don't know if it's
an asian thing but like um like i like i always like i like
every time we like you know like uh my parents are like for
hotels and stuff they're always like oh we gotta get the
highest floors because the higher the floor you are the more
important you are or like the more like the better the room
is the better the place is but like i i i don't understand
the reason why like i don't i i don't i i don't understand
the reasoning i'd rather it be like is it less noise is that
it uh Higher is better.
I guess it's like less bug.
Is that really...
Is it like less bugs or what?
I don't understand.
Closer.
I like something.
It's closer to heaven.
I don't understand.
Because I'd rather be like closer to the floor.
Because like...
I feel it's just I don't know like like you know if there's
a fire alarm I don't have to walk down like like so many
stairs like I guess oh less noise from the streets I guess
so I guess I guess that makes sense I I couldn't understand
it at first but at least you I think it's good better it's
good that you guys are smarter than me because I would be
fine living closer to the ground Like, I don't really care
too much about, I guess, like, I'm so used to living in
apartments that's, like, at higher floors, that, like, I
didn't realize it also potentially mean, it potentially
means less bugs, which is a good thing, because I have my
windows open, and, like, bugs that have made it to my floor,
like, they deserve to be in here, because, like, I live,
really, I live, like, really high up, so, If they manage to
fly all the way up here, then, like, good for them.
You know what?
They've made it.
They made it.
It's like a pilgrimage.
They finally made it.
They won only up.
Yeah, they won only up.
They deserve to be here.
Lusagi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, it's your first.
Super chats, too!
Thank you!
Also, I'm sorry I didn't read Super chats yesterday during
the sponsored stream.
I got so absorbed into Neopets that, like, um, I forgot all
about, like, reading uh, the Super chats.
I'm so sorry.
There were so many first-time Super chatters, too.
Uh, but thank you so much for the Super chat, Sagi.
Thank you.
Uh, towards your new headphones.
So happy to be here for Digimon.
Who's your favorite Digimon?
Oh, I talked about it, but it's Betzumon.
If you talk about joke Digimon, uh betzuman but like if
you're talking about actual my favorite digimon i always say
it's like uh it's gatomon all the digimon in uh all the
digimon starters for tamers uh because they're all peak i
think digimon tamers had all the peak digimon designs um and
uh i like uh um and i think paraman is ugly everyone was
always saying like oh padamon is like the mascot digimon
just like how pikachu is the mascot pokemon um but i'm like
why padamon he's so fucking ugly i i don't understand he's
not cute at all i think he's just a if you take away his
wings he's just a giant potato with legs giant thumb with
legs if you think about it like you just if you draw you
take your thumb out and you put wings on it that's padamon
that's no people would say that padamon you guys were like
no the mascot is agamon no back then back then everybody
would say like padamon is like the cute mascot for digimon
back then um and they would make like so much merch for
because like like merchandise which i understand because
it's literally a thumb with wings um but like back then it
was padamon uh where they kept like pushing padamon
everywhere now it's agumon because like now they're like oh
agumon was actual the actual like main mascot for digimon
but even then like uh they would make so much merch of
padamon back then because they're like padamon's the main
character they would push padamon everywhere in na and i
thought he was like the ugliest one of the ugliest digimon
in the franchise i don't don't uh you just hate me because
i'm right
you just it's exactly it's a it's a bean with wings it's a
giant thumb with wings it's not even cute is that they booed
her because she's right there was so many more cuter digimon
than padamon okay digimon um season one like okay i have to
admit though like um oh my god her padamon's so ugly
compared to everybody else like
Just looking at, I'm looking at, like, the Digimon, uh, the
Digimon variants in season one.
I mean, look at this.
All right.
Compared to every other Digimon there for the Digi Destin.
Like, look at all the Digimon for the Digi Destin.
Like, okay, Agumon, I would admit, it's not, like,
everybody's favorite.
Because, like, even though he's, like, a Dino, um, he's,
like, a very, he has, like, a chest of a human, like, a, a,
a chest of a human so like i can understand where people are
like um agumon is like not their thing because honestly for
me it was also bad to me too i never liked agumon because
like his chest is literally like uh like that of like um um
of like a person that might have like let themselves go a
little bit uh yeah he's got the he's He's got the dad bond.
I will admit, he's got the dad bond.
And so like, I wasn't like a huge fan of Agumon.
So I wasn't, okay, I wouldn't say I didn't like Agumon.
Like I have, I was just like indifferent to Agumon.
I hated Padamon because they kept pushing Padamon as like
the main cute mascot of Digimon.
And I hated his design because I thought like Padamons.
design was like so ugly and i still do um like padamon
plushies aren't even cute like i it okay official padamon
plushie is not even cute like i like okay this is like what
they sold back then for like um they were like selling like
you know like it's it's very hard to get digimon merch i'll
just say i remember like back then it was so difficult to
get digimon merch in the west popular at all and and like it
was popular but not as popular as pokemon because like you
know pokemon was here first in um in the west um even though
i would say the anime series is so much better versus uh uh
versus pokemon um and i feel like they just didn't have like
a lot of good games they just the biggest downside for
digimon in the west is that they didn't have a lot of good
but like look at this ugly fucker
they still don't it's really difficult to make Digimon games
but like um like oh my god he's so ugly like I just never
liked what how he looked I fully you're wrong okay like but
like you're you're just mad because you know there's like
better like terry remon it should have terry i bet you like
um if terry remon was in season one like he would be the the
he would have beaten pikachu terry remon would have 100
beaten pikachu if he was created in season one like he has
everything that Pikachu wishes.
made Pikachu.
Pikachu used to be a fat fuck.
And then like he got skinnier and skinnier into like
Teriomon bides.
Pikachu fat.
Pikachu.
Okay.
There you go.
Like.
Okay.
Let's see.
I mean there's like the evolution.
Like look at him.
This is like Teriomon had that body.
Before Pikachu became skinny.
They shouldn't make him.
They shouldn't make him fat again.
Like.
Look at this.
This is literally Terrier Mon.
Terrier Mon was first.
Terrier Mon had this first.
This is literally Terrier Mon.
Are your eyes okay?
Bad Pikachu, my boy.
Alright, Terrier.
Okay, Digimon Tamers.
When the Digimon Tamers come up?
Digimon Tamers came out in 2001!
Skinny Pikachu was 2010!
You guys are like, i used to love fat pikachu yeah but it
was oh my gosh okay um wait uh pikachu okay the reason i
feeling one of the reasons why oh my god okay i looked up i
looked up i look up fat pikachu plush and i got this i'm
sorry i should be playing the game but like i i'm i'm a
little bit too absorbed right now in in in pikachu versus
terry herman but look at look at Look at this absolute unit,
though.
This is unrelated to my conversation, but, like, I really
want...
I really want it in this chest list.
I want this.
What the fuck?
Can I buy this?
Where can I buy one of these fat Pikachu plushies?
Wait, I want to buy one, too.
Oh, my God!
No!
They don't call them!
Mochi Pikachu plushie!
Yeah!
No!
They don't sell these guys any!
I should want this.
Wait, what the fuck?
This is amazing.
I want this.
That's the strongest Pikachu.
Oh my god.
I love this plushie.
Okay.
Anyway.
Sorry, I got a little off topic before.
But I feel like one of the main reasons why...
like Pikachu like got like the proportions of Pikachu change
was because like the plushies just didn't look cute at all
like I I thought they look cute but like I guess when you
compare to like current Pikachu plushies versus like Pikachu
plushies now um like they're just like it's harder to make
older Pikachu plushies because of the proportions it's not
marketable enough because of the proportion size for
plushies and like it feels like it's harder to make but I
used to own this.
I was trying to find this plushie.
I was trying to find this guy.
And, like, this is the one I actually owned this plushie.
I used to own this as a little kid.
I remember because I, like, loved this plushie so much back
then.
That's what I'm saying.
Digimon back then didn't have, like, a lot of merch, too.
It didn't have, like, as much merch as Pokemon, which was
really sad.
but yeah anyway um anyway if terry omon existed back when
pikachu was like the main contender terrymon would have won
like 100 like look at him he's so cute in his floppy ears
and like honestly like terrymon would beat the shit out of
pikachu because he he digivolves into something with guns i
don't for those who are not familiar with digimon how they
do uh evolution
they are the more guns they get like for those who uh okay
gargomon yeah he he garg i forgot his evolution um oh yeah
and he has pants too i would admit gargomon is not pretty is
not as pretty as terryomon um anyway like i mean he has guns
for hands like
For those who, uh, for those who, like, uh, don't know,
understand, like, Digimon, Digivolution, um, basically,
like, in order, the stronger they get, um, the, the more
guns they have, because I'm pretty sure, like, after
Gargomon, he Digivob's into, like, some guy with, like,
missiles.
Oh, yeah, there you go.
Okay, and then he turns into a Mecha, Rapidmon.
Um, this is, like, his, his, his next evolution or
Digivolution, which is basically like missiles.
So this is how they're, I know, okay.
I would admit, like, for those who are like, oh, he's not as
cute when they get older, I could understand that.
But like, but they have guns!
They have guns and missiles, though!
look they have missiles and guns that's all that matters uh
um envy thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
terrymon also has the six sister unit lopoma who turns into
an oh yeah i know about lopoma i don't like lopoma because i
don't like her color scheme i think like um i prefer i i
prefer terrymon over lopoma because like i feel like
terrymon's color scheme is a lot cuter than uh loper man's
color scheme um so i i personally prefer uh i personally
prefer terrymon more also i think lopelman just has too too
many horns because lopelman has three horns and i'm like
that's too many horns like what the fuck are you doing with
all those horns like it turns into a okay but before it
turns into a cool demon into a like i don't want to say it
but like you know before the before the demon um
digivolution it turns into like like a very ugly one and
then it turns into a cooler cooler anyway um yeah i'm
talking about when okay so before before it turns into like
the cooler demon it turns into wendy goman which is like in
my opinion like not really not that pretty not that it's
pretty but but it's after that after that he turns into a
more handsome digimon all right let me room sorry i got like
so off topic i'm sorry i i get like passionate um about
stuff i tend to like i i i get way too passionate all right
um the reason why i didn't have the game booted up is that
the game starts playing in a um a opening so uh that's why i
didn't have it open because i want you guys to watch the
opening i didn't even watch the opening yet too all right
here we go oh it's made in unity
Oh no, it's copyrighted.
Oh no, they're going to get five cents off of this vibe.
Oh no, what are they going to do?
Tell my company?
You mean the company that I own?
Oh, it crashed.
What the fuck?
Okay.
No, they got me!
They got me!
They got me, guys!
Game Proofs, God.
I got live cut.
No!
Oh no, I got, I have to listen to the music again.
Oh no.
Now there's John Digimon!
They hit me live!
It would be funny if it like crashes at the exact moment
too.
I don't wanna know.
It's a good song though.
Watch it crash again.
kid all right for this you don't know sorry i never
explained the game but digimon world next order is like the
spiritual sequel i don't know if it's like sequel sequel i
would say like spiritual sequel to the original digimon
world um and digimon world was like the very first uh ps
game i ps1 game i've ever played but it was in japanese
didn't know what i was playing like i didn't know what was
going on but like i love the shit out of it like it was like
one of my favorite ps1 games oh is it a sequel sequel a
full-on sequel i feel like the only sequel part is that it's
like the mechanics are like um are basically the same but
like it's it doesn't build off of the original world from
what i heard um and they they do jrpgs but back in the day
they experimented a lot with digimon games wild next order
digimon world they like they like digimon okay the reason
why pokemon is also more popular in digimon is that they had
a formula and they stuck it the entire like the entire time
they existed they found the most successful formula and but
digimon Digimon had like the weirdest history because it
started off as like the male equivalent male male version of
tomagachis um because tomagachis was really popular females
and then they were like well we want males to we want guys
like little boys to play play a tomagachi like games too so
they made Digimon and that's why they have more guns because
they're like what do boys like Oh, yes, violence and guns.
Let's just add.
Let's add.
Let's give them guns.
Let's get these Tamagotchi pets guns.
That's what the little boys like.
That's what I'm like.
That's sort of why the designs that this, because they're
like, oh, in Pokemon people love Charmander.
And um so so that's why the designs tend to have lots of
guns and missiles and tanks and dragons and dinosaurs
because they're like what do the little boys like back then
oh yes dinosaurs and guns so then they combine the two
together and make digimon um anyway anyway after that
they're like what should the next series be when it comes to
gaming and so they went with like oh let's let's Digimon
World the first uh the next game they made for the console
next-gen console so like then they went with Digimon World
um and that was also like the like like you know it was like
pet raising and fighting other Digimon but they die okay I
need to let you guys now know Digimon die in this game um
and they don't come back they're gone forever so I'm gonna
make name all my Digimon after dragoons so uh anyway the
stakes are are very high here um and um and then digimon
world 2 oh yeah and then digimon world 2 they made it a
dungeon crawler so they went away from the original digimon
world concept and then they made it into a dungeon crawler i
own digimon world 2 and i was like i thought it was gonna be
like digimon world 1 and then so when i bought digimon world
2 I was very disappointed.
I was very...
I remembered.
I remembered as a kid.
I was so excited.
It was the one...
Wait, the character was like a Digimon with a sword in his
mouth, right?
I don't remember.
They made a new Digimon just for Digimon World 2.
And I was so sad because...
I was so sad because I was like...
I loved Digimon World 1 even though I didn't really know how
to play it because it was all in Japanese.
But I really enjoyed the game.
But then so when I got Digimon World 2 and it was in
English, I was so happy I was so I was so happy because oh,
it wasn't the sword.
Was it not the sword Digimon?
That was four Okay, I need to look up Digimon World 2 now.
I'm like, I'm like getting my Digimons confused because
Every Digimon World.
Oh, no, it wasn't Digimon 2.
Um, it was four.
Yeah, four.
Yeah, Digimon World 4 was so weird They had swords.
Oh, wait, okay.
All right, let me, let me, okay.
So every new Digimon World game was so weird.
It was so different.
It was, because they didn't know what to do.
And it was like, so that's why I felt like, okay, so this is
the game I played.
The next Digimon World game I played was four.
But I went from Digimon World 1 to 4.
And I was like, what is this?
like why do they have why why do they have swords i was so
confused like i didn't know what was going on i was so
confused so like but every digimon world is like different
it's so different and I remember Digimon World 3 I remember
I remember My dad bought me Digimon World 3 And I had no
idea How to play 3 Because 3 was like an RPG And so I was
like Okay and then I went And then I got And then I
personally bought Digimon World 4 Because I was like Oh my
god Digimon World 4 Maybe this one will be similar And then
Digimon World 4 was like you run around with swords killing
other Digimon and I'm like what I was like where are the
people so so this is what like and I had no friends uh so
well I had friends but they don't play video games so like
as like you know like all my I had I didn't really have
friends that play video games so like this was digimon world
4 and it was so different it was actually it was so
different from like the other digimons i play like i played
um and so like i was like literally the only girl that in my
class that played video games or consoles and like i didn't
really hang out with the guys uh other than like oh and my
parents would not let me invite anybody over so like i
over to my house was when i was like nine years old i think
yeah nine years old for a class project and like that was
like literally the only time i've ever had like uh people
over my house because i was not allowed to have people over
my house so like i had the very first time was when i was
nine and it was a class project and then we played video
games together and instead of doing our project.
I had to say, I said doing our class project.
So I've always played video games by myself.
I've always played.
So I had no friends to play Digimon World 4 with me.
So I thought it was dog shit.
I was like, I don't like this.
I can't play this solo.
It's not a good solo game.
This game was definitely not meant to be played by yourself.
thought it was a bad game but then i saw people in my chat
was like oh i had a great i had i had a great time playing
with all my friends in digimon world 4 i was like i didn't
have friends to play this game with is that why i thought it
was dog is that is that why anyway as i was saying um
digimon did not know what its identity was when it came to
video games because Every fucking iteration of a Digimon
game is so different.
And now they're doing JRPGs because CyberSmooth did really,
really well.
So, like, I, okay, I was sad because I thought Digimon
Survive was supposed to be, like, a horror game.
Because, like, I was like, oh, a Digimon horror game?
Oh, my God.
I can't, I'm so excited.
A Digimon horror game.
And then I found out it was, like, a visual novel.
advertised survive felt like it was um um the way they
advertise survive at first it was like i felt like it was
like a horror more so like an action not action but like um
you know what i mean when like not like a visual novel but
more of like gameplay wise that it's not i didn't realize it
was like a visual novel gameplay uh game and i'm not like a
huge fan of like visual novels in general because that's a
lot of reading.
That's a lot of reading.
I know like CyberSnoop is like really good, but it's a JRPG
and I'm not a JRPG player.
So like it's not my type of genre.
So like when they announced Survive, I was so excited
because I was like, oh my God, like that's like something
they never really done before, like a horror, like more so
of a horror element.
So I was like super hyped up and then I found out it was
visual novel and then I didn't touch it.
So I was just like, I was like, visual novel guess guess I
guess I won't be touching that game anymore I also heard
they released a horror anime based off of Digimon as well
which was I thought it was really interesting um that's why
like in the west it was Digimon was not as popular um it was
not as popular as it
didn't establish an identity early on in pokemon when they
had like such a dominant force in in the west in na that
like uh they just like took over they literally uh they
literally got like it literally got taken over that was just
too late like they had such a strong hold in the market when
it comes to like you know uh a little like like monster
companions that was so hard for digimon to like um expand
more after that but i still like digimon more than pokemon
because i personally think that their their the anime and
the designs are a lot better than pokemon even like the more
recent designs i feel like digimon is much more creative
when it comes to like the more recent iterations i do not
personally do not like the newer designs of pokemon and like
Newer designs for Pokemon is more so markability in terms of
merch than like what actually looking Good to me.
I don't know.
This is my personal opinion, but I feel like It's the
designs are not as good as it once was because I feel like
the more recent ones The it's so simple like I'm not simple,
but there's just something Off of it about it for me like
it's just there's something off about the newer pokemon
designs uh and um and so like that's why like even the
starters too i'm not like i don't really like the newer
starters designs lately um but i feel like digimon designs
in my opinion the newer designs i do like a lot more um
because they're not afraid to do like more uh complicated
stuff when it complicated more memorable stuff versus like
uh pokemon um because like some of the designs that digimon
does is like what the how do you make that like a marketable
plushie like it looks cool it looks cool but like How do you
make that, like, a fucking plushie?
Like, how do you...
Yeah, Digimon is, like, more experimental when it comes to
their designs.
I heavily agree.
Um...
All right.
Anyway, we're going to start the game for real.
Sorry.
I just realized I've been talking for 42 minutes, and we
haven't even played the game.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
I love...
I love Digimon.
easier for those who just want not for for those familiar
with the world i'll do easy um if i do normal guys you can't
be like no joki do normal don't be a pussy if i do normal
you guys will die in like less than a day so um do you guys
want to live and survive and live out your life until you're
elderly or do you want to die the moment you like poop like
i am ready to die oh the girl's cute wait shiki is so much
cuter than takuto i think that's his name oh i don't like
the blue thing coming out of his head like i know that's his
hair but i just i'm not like a huge fan of that i'm not i
think i think shiki's cute please enter the name oh me dokey
the cuter dokey oh okay cute okay is this a one two three
four five one two three four five six seven eight okay cuter
dog okay cute dokey there you go that's eight we'll die for
the content
Oh my god, I got chosen!
I got chit-chit-chit-chosen!
It's not an Isikai.
I mean, technically it is an Isikai, but like I basically
got transported into the digital world.
The digital world.
We're going to become digital champions.
Oh.
There's something over there.
The chat, Dad.
How the fuck did you guys do that?
die like what happened how did you guys die okay give me a
sec let me fix it i don't i don't know i actually don't know
why it does that i don't know if it's like the chat css or
if it's uh just something to do with um um the new obs don't
worry i fixed you guys okay the volume is low you know
what's funny um it's not letting me go to my settings Can I?
Oh, I cannot.
Guys, I literally cannot go to the settings here.
They locked me in.
They locked me in here.
Yeah, I was going to say, it's not really an Isakai.
Because the digital world is part of this world.
It's just the digital world.
We're literally in your computers.
Oh, no, he's evil.
Machine Dream on.
Can I pet it?
He's so cool.
What the fuck is that guy?
Oh my god.
Wait, that wasn't you two?
Get back.
We can take it from here.
Oh yeah, by the way, they can talk.
For those who are not familiar with Digimon, they can talk
to us.
You just need to give us commands as usual.
It's like a grown man in this dog.
What is it?
You've always given us commands in battle.
Oh, they're my Digimon!
You seem really confused all of a sudden.
It can't be helped.
We'll back you up.
He's got that dog in him.
You've got to be kidding me.
You're not supposed to forget us.
Your partners.
Alright, Digimon battles.
In pursuit of victory, your partner Digimon will choose and
attack targets of their own accord.
However, teamers can use orders to command them more
directly.
Open order ring for partner L.
I had two?
I had to multitask?
Okay, um, I can do this.
Um, left stick order.
So you can open the ring.
Oh.
Okay, I'm glad I had coffee.
Hi.
How long you have left to give it before the ring closes?
The timer stopped when she was ordered, but only for five
seconds.
The ring closes the timer here is here and you'll have to
wait five seconds to open it again.
Try it out.
Okay.
Order War Greymon to use the Mac Jab.
Arby and Tilt Left, then press A.
Okay, I need to use the Jab.
There they are.
Um.
Mac Jab.
Alright.
Do your thing.
Oh, he did it!
Okay, and then next try I use Agitation.
Metal Garumon.
Okay.
I can do this.
I metal.
Where's meta where is it oh no i'm sorry man i'm gonna move
on oh agitated it was right here okay nice we'll let him
automatically recover hp for pure time there are various
types of agitation time used as a digimon um inherit
abilities he added more order power for stronger order power
you need okay for strong orders you need more order power So
you're for your partners to build more order power press a
buttons to support war gray mom until you gathered 150 when
a partner attack has hit and after taking damage That's your
chance after using support you will need to wait a bit
before using it again Okay, is he doing it is he doing it?
support Go go go I'm cheating them on You're getting the
hang of it i am i don't know if i am does it look like i
know what i'm doing guys
whoa oh my god he's doing the thing it's the terror force i
remember that in the anime i'm beginning to believe
so strong no good no I have to keep going I've finally met
my tamer this is where I'm a goner I finally met you guys
you can't give up you finally met me guys gotta keep going
yeah I see we may be defeated here but we won't let that
Too cute Doki What is doing for Doki of a bond?
Oh my god, we're bonding The bond is transforming into power
Let's go as long as you're with us.
Yeah, we can still fight you don't want to be losers You're
winners dragons you're winners You gotta keep going!
Alright, LB to open for both.
Normally, the icon here is where Digifuse skills.
In certain circumstances, EXE will be available.
At the same time, and tilt, then press A.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, let me out of the ring of destruction.
Okay.
Uh...
Alright, what's this?
Extra cross evolution?
America Digivob?
Are we fusing?
Oh, the BGM!
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum, bum.
Digimond the OG is the guy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Gothamette.
Oh, my God, you're fusing.
Where are you going to become?
Oh.
Oh, that guy!
I forgot his name.
Is it Omega Mon?
Omega Mon!
his arm oh shit he gets a sword and gun
success with exe your partner digimon will fuse into extra
powerful forms after the battle is over your digimon will
separate again guys we're gonna guys we can't fall in love
with this digimon because he's gonna die that's the whole
point of this game wait is
he dead wait wait he's wait he's did he die no you can't die
what we lost this isn't the time to be sleeping we must
offend our partner i
love how like the cutscene audio is so quiet There is a
game.
I can't believe it.
Right after they digifuse, they fucking just die like that?
Wait, they won.
Then what was the point of fusing?
What's the point of...
What was the point of fusing if, like, they're just better
separately?
Some people are just not meant to be together.
Oh, yeah, and then when they died, they just devolve.
So now they're a baby.
You're all right.
Yay!
What about you, dragoons?
How old are you guys?
Are you guys going to die of old age soon?
Oh.
Oh, I guess they're dead.
Just Just one thing Peace
Okay Okay Oh no, no, you guys are fine It seems like A human
A machine Dremon Disappears and a human Appears Fascinating
Oh, it's him It's Gigi-Mon This person was in caught in the
interdimensional this guy was in the first digimon world
game you defeated that machine draymon that must be what
destabilized the other dimension these must be your partners
yeah dragon one and dragon two that's an odd relationship
okay wait what what i can't have two digimons like If
Pokemon can have six, I can have two.
They did everything they could to defend you.
Don't make it weird.
I'm not making it weird.
He's making it weird.
I'm going to have three Digimon too.
That little guy right there is going to join the squad.
Why did Mom let you have two Digimon?
No need to look so depressed.
They were partner Digimon.
So it is possible to revive them with a Digi egg.
I have preserved them in external storage.
Wait, did they actually die?
Oh shit.
Oh, seven.
That was fast.
Goodbye, Dragon one and Dragon two.
So, hold your partner in your heart.
Goodbye, dragon one and two.
That was so fast.
Wait, isn't this Terrier Mon?
Wait, which one's...
Okay, I want Gato Mon.
I'm trying to remember...
I'm trying to remember which one was which.
But Digivolution Details.
Tsuno Mon.
Which one was this?
Toko Mon.
It has hands and feet.
It's cute, but it has...
Oh, this one is the...
It's the triangle.
It's a yellow cat, right?
Okay, but like, which one...
This one's Gato Mon.
Which one is this one?
I don't remember this one.
Gummy Mon?
That grew from Bright and Cheerful.
It has a high horn.
Which one was this one?
Is that Terrier Mon?
That's Terrier?
That's Terrier Mon?
I'm gonna get Terrier Mon.
Oh my god, this is so difficult.
I don't know if I should get Teri-R-Mond or Gato-Mond.
Oh, I'm gonna get Teri-R-Mond.
I like Teri-R-Mond more.
This is Lopo.
I know this is Lopo-Mond, and this is... I'm gonna get...
Oh, it's so difficult!
Okay, when Teri-R-Mond dies, I'm gonna get Gato-Mond later.
Yay!
Dragon 3 and 4, let's go.
Mewis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Zerimon!
Oh, I get two!
I can get Gato-mon and Terrier-mon.
Oh my god.
Dragon 3.
No!
That's okay.
Dragon 3.
What are more words?
I can't do that.
How would you know there's one or two more?
Terrier-mon is not even a real word.
Dragon-mon.
Two mod.
Three.
One.
Is it because it has good?
Drammon three.
Goodmon three.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's not fair.
You may.
Oh now I can't even enter eight letters.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
That's seven.
What?
Okay, dragmon three.
What do you mean?
So, hold your partner in your heart and hope for the best.
Wait, I didn't name him.
I didn't.
Did I...
What?
What happened?
Wait, what happened?
Did I...
Wait, I didn't name him!
What did I do to him?
No!
Now he's just default, man!
You went bad.
No!
Okay, we're gonna grab our Gatomontu.
Oh, I can rename him later.
Thank God.
I can't believe Goon is a bad word.
Did she buy?
Oh, you give me a...
Oh, I'm sorry.
They get like...
Like 200,000...
Oh, I'm sorry.
That is more than eight letters.
This is more than eight letters.
This is not fair.
That's like...
50 like why can you keep me and put them on 50 letters and
i'm restricted to eight i can't believe it okay drag mon um
drag mon for you may enter that's not fair Oh, we use Roman
numerals.
Guys, what's the Roman numeral for four again?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
What's the Roman numeral?
IV, okay.
God damn it, okay.
Dre, Dre, man, IV.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god, that's our way.
That's how we're gonna do this.
This is a tremendous number.
Roman numeral.
then their rebirths will be complete we can't go in the bad
way just remember as their tamer you have a duty to care for
them okay
you don't seem to understand what's what i am just as in the
dark as you i wonder what is going why don't we go to my
house and you can tell me your story okay looks like tokamon
is still unconscious wait is tokamon not gonna be my digimon
I thought I can't have three so
you were sucked in by the digivice and unluckily fell into
the dimension i created wait your god and then your partners
is there a god in digimon defeated machine draymon for me i
see coincidence has been our friend today i owe you my
thanks actually there's like 12.
as you can see the city we are in floaty is in disarray
what's happening in flotia it's because of the machine
draymon yeah him i made him small now for no reason and did
a lot of damage to the city oh i can use goon you just can't
use your mural oh okay i know what to name our digimon now
it appeared massive damage and then disappeared we were at
our wit's end I mobilized my knowledge and technology to
build a trap in order to capture the machine Draymon.
I thought that when it appeared, I could transport it to
another dimension and imprison it.
The plan worked.
In fact, the plan went even better than expected.
Thanks to you, we were able to defeat that machine Draymon.
but that doesn't mean the danger has entirely passed the
phenomenon of a machine Dremon getting violent and then
disappearing there's more there's more of them in many areas
it would be hard to believe that it is just one lone mega
Digimon doing all this damage so there's more of them that
we have to stop time because of your valiant efforts
unfortunately we don't know from where and how the machine
draymon are appearing it seems hopeless but if we just had a
clue maybe we could do something if only just take off take
away all the digimon that like did you evolve into machine
draymon and teach them about the power of good that's it's
just that because they come from a specific line of Digimon
and all we have to do is make sure they don't go evil what
this Tokemon was the machine Dremon it can't be no but I am
sensing a strange data wave every evil machine Digimon then
we'll get all the machine Digimon should we make of this a
tocomon living in this city digivolved into a machine
draymon i've never heard of such a yeah all the tocomons
together and teach them the power of good in the cloud
memory but why did this just delete the code or we just
delete the code get the code and just delete the line that's
all we need to do we won't be able to figure it out with
just this small amount of information from this tokamon but
it looks like we finally have a chance to actually do
something about this threat we need to act i have something
to ask of you just erase them it's like they never existed
in the code to the world you came from as soon as possible
but we can't leave this city in the state it's in to get the
city back to the way it was.
Will you help bring back the residents that fled from the
machine Dremon attacks?
Why don't you do it yourself?
Yeah, old man.
I would do it myself, but there are too many children in the
city.
I can't leave them alone.
I can babysit the kids.
So, go out with your partners.
Wait, why?
How come... Oh my god, I just realized he has like giant ass
feet.
But like, why is he allowed to just like we look into this
small amount of strange data we have collected from you have
more information about the the people outside the city than
me i just got here to unravel the mystery he's old he's not
old it's just what he looks like if we can detect abnormal
information you can't grow old in digimon you just die
that's why i first intend to make a detection device that's
what he looks like he's not a real person he's a digimon he
was programmed to look like this so please check your digi
he was born oh so then i'm counting on you he's literally an
old mad digimon okay it's not much but all of us got these
items for you oh thank you koromon oh my god I got portable
toilet Okay guys For those who are like Why do you have a
portable toilet If you don't poop You're actually You die
You get You turn like ugly apparently If you don't poop You
turn ugly Your digivolution So I gotta make sure you like I
gotta I gotta make sure You use the bathroom.
How do I...
How do I like...
Oh, there we go.
It's why.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta bring...
Oh my god, he yapped a lot.
Okay, we gotta bring stuff down.
Okay, voice.
We bring down voice a little bit.
And then we bring down music a little bit too.
Alright.
And then we'll bring this down as well.
Alright, that should be good.
I want to rename you.
How do I rename?
Oh, I got Digimail.
Bring Digimon to town.
We got to look at the nine planes.
Partner.
How do I change your name?
Zeriormon.
How do I change your name, guys?
I'm going to rename you.
I want to rename you guys.
How do I do it?
to be cut.
Oh, I could...
Uh, Baka-mon?
That's not Baka-mon.
That's Gigi-mon.
Who are you?
Pune-mon.
We want to talk about it.
I can tell you all you need to know about battle.
Okay, not that.
Uh, you're not Baka-mon.
You're Kodomon.
Oh, I have a chest.
Who are you?
That's Poyomon.
Dimensional boxes?
What the fuck is that?
Alright.
Presents.
Oh, do I get presents?
Omega, all Digivolution?
Oh, what the fuck did I receive?
Battle Rankings.
Okay, we're not fighting.
Oh, that's PvP.
Oh, I have new mail.
Daily quest.
Gather three quick fruits.
Oh, I get 3,000.
Oh, my gosh, there's quests and everything.
The longer I wait, the... Oh, that's you guys!
The 4HC now is the one and Gigi Ma and the rest of us have
work to rebuild.
But you're all children.
How are you rebuilding?
Oh, Kiyo-Doki, hold on.
Yeah?
I'll show you around Fusha and teach you all sorts of
things.
But you're a child!
How are you teaching me?
You're literally a child.
Okay.
Yeah, I need a tour guide anyway.
They're actually all kids!
Who let these kids work here?
why are you letting children run the city is this the
children town the infamous town for kids that shut down the
name is tainmont um why do you think it was super chat thank
you thank you there isn't a single game that wouldn't be
improved with a poop mechanic not a single one so weird
about that.
Who would let the kidnation?
Oh my god, it's kidnation all over again.
Okay, here, if not enough, go get some mushrooms or
something.
When your partners are hungry, give them some meat.
Uh, you picked up.
Oh, there's the portable potty.
And you know what comes up?
That's why we have a bathroom here.
As for a bathroom break, you'd better hurry on over here.
Um, next to that is the training hall the training hall is a
very important facility uh they'll explain everything when
you go inside okay yeah you guys gotta train too it's a
train your partner digimon for now I'll give you a real
rough rundown touch this to do some training the training
input will pop up setting confirm what gear you want to
partner one time takes a single hour it makes a Digimon
tired keep an eye on the fatigue and the attitude they could
get sick or life could diminish if that happens.
Let them rest on this bed.
Oh, he's so cute.
Talk to Chijima when it's time to rest.
When the sleep sign appears, let them sleep in care mode.
Oh, my God, look at him.
He's so cute.
Alright.
If there's anything you don't get after that, ask Sunomon
and Mutimon about it.
They're all children.
They're actually all just...
Because, like, okay, by the way, these aren't he's gonna be
supposed to be children because these are babies.
Oh no, these are these are babies and then these guys are
like adolescents or something they're like they're like
they're like toddlers.
Yeah, these are like I was just born and these are like
babies.
So like I'm literally asking babies on what to do.
They're rookie.
Then you want to see this white machine here.
When you train power build up when the power fill up so you
can improve that gear.
But there's no Digimon in the city that can do improvements
yet.
I'm a master at training.
Go on.
Ask me.
You're a child.
You're not a master of anything.
You're literally a child.
Trainers focus more around adjusting digivolution-related
skills, but another important part is food effects.
Food items can be divided into eight types.
Uh, no thank you.
I don't really want to know.
All right, let's start training one of you guys.
Let's train.
You can chain your party positions with the left and right
stick.
Sats on both sides around the increase a little.
For example, if strength is set, then stat and speed will
also increase a little.
Bonuses are shown on both sides.
If you have a bonus, the stat will increase more.
Confirm with A.
Okay.
Uh.
I want you guys to be strong.
I want you guys to be... You're not.
You don't need wisdom.
Alright.
Go.
Play the world.
Yo.
Press A to stop spinning.
You'll win once indicated.
Then you time it well and you may get...
Oh!
Wait, which one is it?
It's this.
Alright.
Yay!
Each time a Digimon train, fatigue increases.
They're in danger when their fatigue level is over 50%.
Give them rest or let them sleep.
Oh, it doesn't matter which one you hit.
Any icon?
Oh, okay.
You guys are fine.
Are you guys How do I get you guys out of here?
Oh, no.
After in training, too, I can definitely...
After in training, too, I can definitely div-drop into
something.
I'm going out now.
I'll think it over.
Alright.
I guess you guys have to keep training.
Oh, you guys are hungry?
Um... I'm sorry.
I...
Be serious.
sorry they won't let me give you guys food so uh you can oh
i can feed them here items all right where is it meat how do
i feed you guys i'm just gonna let you starve i'm like oh
okay hey guys i have food i would never let you guys starve
but a popular mushroom with digital sports i'm just
Mushrooms.
Meat is so hard to get.
So you guys are going to get mushrooms.
Alright.
Wait down by...
Did I feed both of you guys?
Oh, I did.
Alright.
You're not hungry yet anymore, right?
You're still hungry?
Oh, I didn't feed you!
Sorry.
Hey, everyone!
Sorry, I don't need...
You can tell which one's my favorite.
Come on, eat up!
Here you go.
There you go.
Alright, there you go.
Um.
Now you guys are fine.
Okay.
Alright, back to trading you go.
More strength.
Be strong.
Yay!
Alright.
Now you're stronger.
Are digibobbing?
You're digibbing!
What are you?
Now you're a slime.
Now you're gummy mine.
What about the other one?
Oh, there you go.
You're going to be cat now.
This guy did you bomb too?
Naruman.
Oh, my God.
Please, no, you're not going to be smart.
I can't have Dragoon smarter than me.
It's your rooming time.
Alright, now we leave.
Are you going out?
I think you better least...
Are you not rookie?
Wait, is this not rookie?
Are we still in toddler form?
Is this still... Is this not rookie?
They aren't a rookie yet?
Oh, this is toddler!
Okay, back to strength, guys.
Back to...
More strength.
Wait, is this like revival?
It's MP.
That's magic, right?
Now it's baby two.
All right, back to...
Wait, okay, back you go.
There we go.
Yay!
It's not 50% yet, so I can keep going.
Alright guys, you're still gonna be training.
Alright, let's do it.
You're still more strength.
More strength.
It's Ungabunga time.
No!
I missed it!
Oh, now you're- Who said you can be hungry?
Alright, here we go.
Here you go.
Do you guys need a poop yet?
No, you don't have poop meters.
You're still fine.
Here you go.
You're so meany little ones.
Alright, now they're completely full.
Okay.
Wait, do you need poop?
What is that?
Where are those icons?
Are you guys okay?
Are you...
Oh, dumb meter.
My tummy here.
Alright, let's see.
Um...
Wait, I can check their Digivolution line.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Partner, history.
No, it's more so here.
Oh, no.
Wait, I can make you Renamon?
You're not gonna turn...
No!
That's not fair!
Why do you have to be smart?
You're too dumb to be a cat!
It's not fair!
Why are you too dumb to be a cat?
Alright, I need to I need to turn things down.
Our world is about to digimol.
I'm going to turn it down by another 10 and then music by
another 7.
There we go.
I can't believe it.
Okay, what I can't believe is that you turn into a puppy and
then into a cat.
That one was what I can't believe too either.
I can't believe it.
Rennamon's a rookie?
Rennamon should not be a rookie.
I'm not gonna lie.
Rhythmmon is like a woman.
You can't...
You guys joke.
Damn well.
Rhythmmon is not like a rookie.
Um...
Not wrong.
Okay.
No, he gotta be smart.
Fuck you.
I'm going with Rhythmmon.
I'm going to have woman.
Alright, Terumon.
No!
You don't, you're not even smart!
Terumon's...
You need defense?
Oh my god.
Who the fuck wants Haguruman?
No, none of them is strength or respect for Gauman.
Okay, we need...
We need...
We need defense and speed.
Okay, do you...
Defense speed.
What about you?
We need...
Oh, we don't even have, like, the conditions for Renamon.
Renamon needs fucking magic.
You don't even...
You thought you were involving it.
Okay, we gotta...
Alright, we're just gonna go with Cat.
Renamon is a woman.
I screamed to the police officer.
Thank you for the super chat, guys.
Thank you.
Renamon should not be a rookie Digimon.
How is Renamon a rookie?
Renamon fucking beats the shit out of, like, all the other
Digimon.
She's so tall.
She's so fucking tall.
Wisdom and speed.
God damn, I have to give you guys books now.
Okay.
Let's go.
All right.
You two rest for now.
Wait, can I not make you guys rest?
How do I make you guys rest?
Are you guys not resting yet?
All right, rest.
you guys not resting yes rest yeah if rookie why tall uh
scrooge thank you for the one gift thank you thank you
that's so true why are they tall okay fuck I now need to
figure out what your what your lines are figure out your
evolution line alright um okay you are gonna become
Terriman.
I need stat and speed.
Okay, stat and speed.
And then I have to buy you a...
I need to buy you a book.
Alright, here we go.
Nice.
Stat.
Okay, wisdom.
You went up wisdom.
Now you got a poop?
God damn it!
Get over here.
We're taking you to the party.
They need a poop.
I can't stop.
them from that okay there aren't anything around here yet
but you get a bunch more did you come here call them or
bring him then you can build facility and get to work it all
depends on the effort you put in oh there's a bathroom in
the gym i didn't know that this exit takes you out of the
city outside there are digital that will attack you if you
play it right you could avoid battles entirely things get
dicey head back to the city or i'm gonna get open a digi
vice by pressing y
uh as well as digimales sent to you there what the fuck
happened why are these kids so knowledgeable
that's the end of my explanation thank you for listening all
right they seem satisfied we're in our new strength all
right you guys did great dragoons who's a good dragoon
use the potty now go poop go oh we can't see what there's
literally a door i'm like i'm not gonna watch it like oh
only one of you needs to poop all right get over here what
what do you want me to see all right we gotta make sure
you're a rookie sharpen your skill all right speed wisdom
Are they smart enough yet?
Alright, here we go.
Did they poop together?
Alright, 76.94.
Okay, how much did you guys need?
76.94?
Oh, Mark.
Okay, oh, we got 8.
Okay, 80.
Now you just need MP.
Alright, we need...
Oh, wait, no, that's not what we need.
We need more stats.
Fuck, okay, we need 150.
I'm not turning you into toy Agumon.
You're not going to be Agumon under this roof.
I don't care if this is your calling.
You're never going to be Agumon under this house.
All right.
Let's see.
We still need to be smarter.
You're not going to be Agumon.
If you live under this roof, I will never let you be a
dinosaur.
I need to buy you guys more books Why But don't you I want
to be a dinosaur You don't like this item You think you can
decide what you want to eat Time to eat That's right now eat
this mushroom
Good.
All right, now you're not hungry anymore.
There you go.
Keep this tired, Mom.
All right.
Oh, no bonus.
Pooping with homies is a bonding experience.
You wouldn't get it.
Thank you for the Super Chatcast.
Thank you.
Are you guys there yet?
All right, 94.
Wisdom.
22.
The dinosaurs are closer to dragons than cats.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Are you guys tired?
How are you guys tired already?
How are you guys tired?
What's your tired meter?
Oh my god, you guys are tired.
I should take you to bed.
All right.
Wait, we're still okay.
Wait, I don't know if I should like put you guys.
Don't keep, don't make us read.
Alright.
Now rest.
It's like a bear.
You ate!
You ate the mushroom in the end.
Wait, what?
Are you guys, did you follow me?
No.
No!
I told you!
You cannot turn into Agumon!
No!
Okay.
What am I gonna do with two Agumon's?
What am I...
Let's go.
This is who I am, Mother.
Oh my god, what am I gonna...
You're fucking just insane!
I want to tear your body!
And God told mine What am I fucking gonna do Legos?
Where somebody's just gonna take you apart Except us Why
didn't you make us ugly?
I like thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Oh
my god That Lego looks That Lego is you What am I gonna do
with this?
I don't even know what you can digivolve
Why you did this to us?
I wanted you to be a cat Oh, I guess I leave now Oh, they
seem satisfied with their new strength Through training Very
nice Don't worry, you'll die soon so I can restart.
I hope perfect this formula.
I hope I'll perfect...
Alright.
When do I even get a fucking wizard mod?
You just turned into a person?
I don't want you to be Hyaga mod!
It looks so ugly!
Alright.
What the fuck do I do with you two?
I want to make the city even more wonderful.
The city.
Is it village city?
This is a city.
Where do I?
Where is the guy?
It appears sometimes when you pick up materials.
It gets harder to get...
Uh...
Let's go.
We get to be wizards.
Well, I guess we leave the city now.
Oh, there's Patamon.
Beat him up!
From here on, Digimon will appear to attack you as enemies.
The enemy Digimon react when you approach him.
They will chase you and Tetsuan will start a battle.
A Digimon that doesn't react, maybe one that comes to the
city.
Talk to them with A or get closer.
Trigger an event.
Is that hostile?
Oh my god, there he is.
I hope...
Oh my god, it better be an enemy.
time are you friendly or not no he's friendly are you one of
those humans oh i see you're controlling machine dream on
how dare you mess with floria i'll oh yes yes it's time to
teach paramount a lesson time to teach this giant thumb a
lesson Like, I was like, he's friendly.
Y 'all chill.
He is definitely not friendly.
Use those claws.
Oh, you were not close.
You have to be close enough?
Feed him up.
Yeah, that's right.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Now you got it.
I figured it out.
That's right.
Did you learn your lesson?
It doesn't really hurt.
Let's go back to the town.
Gigi-Mond's waiting.
Potato down.
You know Gigi-Mond?
Don't tell me you're not a bad guy.
Is that right?
My bad.
I got a bit ahead of myself.
I've never seen a human before, you see?
Right then, I'm going back to Flodia.
Give me a holler if you see me out there.
Wait, what does Patamon get me?
Patamon joined the city.
please be proud of us the wild digimon decided to join now
let's find some partner digimon bring them back also the
digimon mark appeared in the lower right corner a notice was
displayed whatever digimail is delivered okay i know that
what new digimail did i get i got mail did you digimon
search going well i picked up lots of information about
digimon and asked the Bodaman in my house to pass it on to
you.
If you need any help, go talk to him.
Wait, wasn't he the one that was like, that's, that can
change names?
Does Bodaman let me change names?
I don't remember what, you guys said that one of them lets
me change names.
I don't remember which one.
Oh, it's Bakuman?
Oh, it's the fish one.
I have good news!
I made my day.
beat him up to come back home the city prosperity is now one
there's still a long way to go it's the fish one okay wait
stop looking at me like that oh my god you're so fucking
ugly oh wait like look at you don't be at least you know
what like you're okay compared to this guy over here How do
you sleep?
I don't understand.
You're asleep?
Let me sleep.
Okay, there you go.
Sleep on the floor.
Mom, please don't hate us.
No, I'm not talking about you.
You look fine.
You're, you know, you're just Agumon, but like, wait.
You, you're a...
You have a face that even a mother couldn't love, and I'm
the mother.
But you, you're great, sweetie.
You look amazing.
It's food time.
All right.
Are you guys satisfied?
You're still hungry?
Freaky Lego mob.
There you go.
I wanted a fucking cat We can do something with you I wanted
a cat
Alright let's Where's Oh yeah we can get another more meat
It's the next day Here's the me 5 You gave me 10 yesterday
Are you Oh Bakamon Alright we gotta change your name Oh yeah
uh i want to change toy agumon okay toy agumon okay goon uh
goon three there you go two four five six seven yeah there
you go goon three wait what i can't do that goon is actually
a name you can't say tree man okay there you go oh my god
tree Dremont Goon is actually bad Alright Let's see, Patamon
No gooning here Leave Duplamon alone Thank you for the super
chat Bad, thank you, thank you And store, I don't need a
store Anything Alright, get over here No goons allowed.
Get over here.
I have to make do with what I have.
Alright, we got five.
We got five more Digimon.
Is there a thing here?
Where?
Where's the thing?
Here?
We can't get down here yet.
What's the thing are you guys talking about?
Alright, let's grab some mushrooms though.
You guys need more food.
Yay!
The game hates us.
No, no.
I don't hate you.
I don't hate you, uh, Draymon4.
It's you and I against the world.
Be strong for your mother.
Holy shit, this guy's huge.
Wait, he's level six.
Are we strong enough?
Well, it's time to find out.
If you guys die, I can always, uh, restart.
You guys do it!
Go, go, go!
Go!
Oh, you're alive.
Oh, you're...
Oh, shit.
You're alive.
Okay.
You can't be mad at me.
You literally died.
I just broke a lie.
You can't be mad at me.
You literally are mad that you ran away, but you literally
almost died in front of me.
I literally ran away so you guys can live.
Oh, you did it.
I was supposed to know he was so much stronger.
All right.
Let's collect some materials.
Mom, you only cared for brother.
I'm going to go to develop the city later.
The amount you can have changes depends on the stamina
partner this month.
When preparing the city to your automatic place into the
city storage.
Oh, okay.
It was like three.
dies our size it was a level 6 champion i'm sorry i'm sorry
that you're too weak if you were a cat you would have won
the fight anyway
it's ready to go the stronger your enemies become you must
build the strength of your partners for now let's go to nine
planes and get used to living with your partner Digimon.
Alright.
Oh, there is another guy.
You guys can take him on, right?
I'll take this opportunity to explain more if you fill.
I fill up your partners.
Let's do this battle to learn.
Oh, I sure went left instead of right.
Use the tactics methods to flee or change target using
items.
Time will be paused when the box is open.
You can select items by moving up and down.
Okay.
item to both partners press l to or rb or rb to change focus
and use items individually um toss the right items or
parties depending on the situation give yourself a big
advantage press x to open the tactics menu time will be
paused when this is open here you can confirm who is
targeting who or abandon a fleet of fight if you choose a
fleet you will be returned to the entrance of the sub arena
press lb or rb to individual commands The top commands
indicate automatic MP usage in battle, and the bottom
command determines the targeted enemy.
Switch these depending on situation and dominate in battle.
Okay, you guys will be fine, right?
Right?
Yeah!
Uh, you!
You guys just do that thing.
Now fight!
Fight!
See, you're fine.
See, it's like nothing bad happens.
level one.
Wow.
It's like, you know, you should have been fighting Digimon
of your own level.
You guys did it!
Yay!
Good thing you guys fought Digimon of your own level, guys.
It's good thing.
Now realize you guys were level one.
this entire time.
Guys, why didn't you tell me you were level one?
Oh, shit, you need a poop.
Okay.
We're gonna head home.
Guys, no, no, no.
Hold in your poops, guys.
Hold it in.
Guys, please.
The city is right beside us.
There's a toilet nearby?
Wait, where's the toilet?
Where's the toilet near?
us.
There's a potty potty.
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
It's over the bridge.
Guys, hold your poop.
Guys, there's a bathroom over the bridge.
No!
I am not wasting my potty potty.
I literally have to.
Hold it.
You're Lego.
How are you supposed to poop?
You're literally Lego.
Guys, we're almost there.
There's the bathroom.
We're almost there.
There, use the bathroom!
With the Lego and move smaller Lego.
Yay.
Now you're happy again.
Thank fucking God.
God.
How are you mad?
I...
Okay, I am a good person.
I don't understand how you can be mad.
I don't understand.
Yay.
Oh.
He can't be that.
strong yeah it's a level three you guys got this it's a
level three one of us is happy the other
come on guys look this is why i love great this is exactly
why gray agumon is like my favorite oh no oh no uh use your
bubble use your bubble Help him!
Help your fucking brother!
Okay, nice.
That's good.
Use your claws, use your claws.
Snow Agumon, go in there!
Okay.
Oh, I can use the big one.
What am I doing?
Oh, I can use Blizzard!
Why?
Femi is the favorite.
Because he's your brother.
You're supposed to love each other.
Without family.
You can't go through the world without the bond of your
brother.
Yay.
Good job.
You did great, guys.
You did great.
Yeah, Green Man's Digi Evolution.
Info.
Oh, I got I got God of mine.
Wait, I can still evolve to God of mine.
It's so fun.
This is why you're my favorite Wait, he can still be God of
mine Okay Oh my god, I still still hope there's still hope
for you.
There's still hope the dream is alive
The dream is still alive okay all right oh my god it's still
alive we we still have a chance to get caught up we still
have a chance to get a cat you were supposed to be terrier
bond but we can still get a cat we can still get a cat okay
that's good all right oh shit i should be healing okay give
me a sec we got our heal wait both of you got the heals nice
all right you're gonna make sure you get that and i'll make
sure you do some bubble beat it up beat up the plant we
don't need more oxygen in the world beat up the plant look i
healed nice go go go Your brother!
All right, and then bubble.
Use the bubble.
Why does it keep fucking beating up Snowgreymon or Agumon?
All right, cheer, cheer, cheer.
You missed!
No!
Your brother!
Your brother needs help!
Fucking help your brother!
Oh my god.
God, let him get hit.
We're doing long live.
He's a favorite.
You can take it.
No!
Oh, wait.
This is sneak up to the city.
What can I say?
I'm a gourmand.
This is a momentous occasion indeed.
You see, I won five green Digi-Stalks.
I don't have them.
Sorry.
I don't have the Digi Stocks.
Oh, no.
You need a Band-Aid?
Okay, don't worry.
I got you.
Uh, we need to give you a Band-Aid.
All right, there you go.
There you go.
You're healed now.
Oh, thank God.
It's okay.
You're okay now.
Toy Agumon knows that he's not the favorite.
even happy all right grab the wood guys yes we can collect
one more time okay I'll collect one more time all right
dragon dragon dragon four is dragon three is still mad why
are you still mad oh no no this is bad this is really bad uh
we gotta we gotta make sure that he's okay here we go all
right nice okay i need your brother does not want to help oh
thank god okay help him stop running away dragon three
We were born together!
Go for it!
That's how you do it!
Oh no!
Please!
He's getting...
Brother!
I refuse!
It's his battle!
You guys!
We're born together!
What happened to the brotherly bonds?
What happened?
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna use claws.
Oh, I missed.
I keep forgetting that you have to be closer to get it.
Toki happens.
No pros got this.
All you do is run away.
Why?
I don't...
Why do you back up?
Just attack him.
You're letting your brother do all the work.
He's the chosen one.
I'm thinking...
Why?
I'm dead!
Holy shit.
It's called dodging.
I'm scared.
Oh, the gas?
How?
How are you out of MP?
Oh my god.
You're still walking away!
I'm used to...
Oh my god.
Your brother is trying his best this is exactly why Snow
Agumon is my favorite this is why Dragon 4 is my favorite
this is exactly why please please why how is you still not
recharging MP enough you never train our MP mother holy shit
oh No, no, no.
How do I leave this area?
I fucked up.
I walked the wrong way.
Oh, no.
They're still chasing me.
Oh, he's gone.
Okay, we gotta pick up this apple.
He's not a fighter.
He's a dancer.
Oh, I got an apple.
All right.
At least he's happy.
All right, we got it.
Oh, there's another green sock.
I'm a Lego.
What about being a little brother?
Or is there your brother under the bus Rule 2, take credit
afterwards?
Why are you mad?
What do you want?
Dragon 3 or 4?
No, you're 4.
You're 3.
4 is better.
Sorry, I lost track of the numbers.
Because you don't love him.
I am a Lego.
all right we got it it doesn't recharge that is not true
drag oh wait there's a there's a mushroom here dragon force
dragon force mp recharge why didn't your mp recharge dragon
three dragon three where was your recharge
golden child when you're hungry okay we'll get food when
we're home we'll get food when we're home guys we're almost
home he's a lay I scold you once because you wouldn't eat
mushrooms I scold you one time just one time because you
were being a picky eater
You don't like this item?
Bad!
Just a minute.
Bad dragon!
Now eat.
Don't eat no!
Good.
Now you're hungry.
Now we're gonna have our fillet.
Alright.
See?
Dragon.
This dragon likes it.
Alright, let's see.
I need to...
I need...
Okay.
Dragon 3, I don't understand why you don't like...
Why don't you like the mushrooms?
Alright, how's your bond with me?
Not so great.
Hey!
You can't tell which one's the favorite child.
I wonder why.
Dragon 4.
You're doing great, sweetie.
You're doing great, Dragon 4.
Dragon 3!
Why are you running away from your mom?
Okay, let's see.
How do I get you to...
What do I need to train you for?
He doesn't even want you close.
Oh, there's a chance you might evolve into wizard mob
because you're malnourished!
Oh, no!
Oh my god There's a chance you're gonna digifob Because you
don't You don't have the way I didn't mean to Oh yeah GG Do
you have like So I've collected all information about all
the Digimon and the city borders I've asked Botaman over
there The hell everything that we learned Have you ever been
fixed?
Just talk to Botaman Okay, don't forget Oh, I thought he has
like free stuff
Dragon Dragon 4 You're doing great You're doing so great I
can't wait for you to turn into a cat soon You're my
favorite Dragon 3 Dragon 3 Get over here Dragon 3 Get over
it Dragon 3 Get over here Get Dragon 3 Get
Let's see.
Starving.
Can you find food?
What about us?
What do I want to get?
I want...
Oh, yeah.
I want to explore more.
Are we fully healed?
How do we heal up?
Do we just rest?
Guys, how do we heal up?
He's actually running away.
How do we heal up?
up go to the resting oh here all right rest i don't know ask
our brother there we go oh my god
um i don't know what to train you guys for i don't know what
was the idea for god oh my all right oh you need a poop okay
don't worry i'll take you guys to the bathroom all right
time to poop guys time to poop i like how all of you guys
associate stuff with like uh with like dragon oh yeah stop
being mad your brother doesn't like it when you're mad
dragon stop being mad
we want attention i'm giving you guys attention is that my
fault you fucking won't need mushrooms all right let's go is
there anything here is there like we gotta go this way oh
wait do we have wait how do we save oh there it is whoa we
did not save our game.
Okay, but who's Dragon?
But who's Dragon 4 in my chat?
Alright, let's go this way.
Where am I supposed to go anyway?
Map.
I'm here.
Where's Star?
Material spot?
Fishing.
Hold.
There's fishing?
Oh, there's fishing.
That's cool.
I volunteer.
What level is he?
Oh, he's level two.
Get him.
It's a goblin.
I would rather die than be.
Wait.
They're not fully healed yet.
What?
I thought they...
I rested.
They're not rest.
Inside you, there are two dragons.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Help your brother.
He's gonna die.
help your brother he's gonna die no oh my god wake up wake
up
how do you heal I don't understand
I didn't know he was gonna die I thought your brother was
gonna help you I thought he was a favorite child that's why
he got instantly rest Dragoon, when Dragoon 3 died, I
fucking just ran.
Yay!
Oh, we got some MP discs too.
The battle and your partner's return.
Yay, you did great, guys!
Great job!
You got, uh, Garden Mon, you got Gato Monz, did you?
Oh, speed.
Oh, Bonds.
Okay, okay, we gotta figure out.
Okay, I gotta pick up this apple, though.
Okay.
Um, how do I...
So how do they heal?
I don't want to use my items.
Oh, God, it's nighttime.
What the fuck?
I did not expect it to be nighttime.
Uh...
Oh, sleep at the end of the day.
Okay.
Alright, Gatoman.
Bonds is there.
is not okay we gotta train up your speed guys uh okay this
is not good that like uh you it's not good that the weight
portion is satisfied so we gotta we gotta make sure that i
mean wizard mod's pretty cool oh speed isn't important oh it
has no speed okay i get it i get it now speed this not
matter.
Alright, let's get all the materials.
Okay, nice.
I like how we're using Dragoon 3 to farm the wood.
Oh, no!
Okay, Dragoon 4 is helping!
Nice.
Map.
Okay, map time.
Wait, how do I...
Map time?
There is a subquest right here.
We're just gonna run from that real quick.
Oh!
Oh, no!
No, no, no, no, no.
Stop chasing.
I want to talk to him.
It's Tentamon.
I was seeing you around these parts.
Hey, wait a minute.
Are you one of the humans?
Boy, howdy.
It must have been fate that brought us together.
I saw something tell you, in fact.
So what do you think?
Have I piped your interest?
Or do you want to... or do you want... I should pick your
nose instead?
Go on and pick it.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Have I picked your interest or well?
Okay.
Alright.
I could tell you were a sharp one.
Now then, check out this Baton Boy.
Ta-da!
A recovery gist.
Just what every tamer needs.
I can let it go for now.
A hundred bits.
Sure, I'll do it.
Really?
Well then, pleasure doing business with you, partner.
Thanks to you, I can finally open my item shop.
I'll have more deals down the line, so give me a holler in
town.
Peace out, ombre.
Yeah, Tentamon!
Tentamon is joining the army.
All right, let's see.
We have to head to...
Oh, fishing.
How do I fish?
Oh, I don't have a fishing rod.
Not yet.
Oh wait, can you guys farm this?
Yeah, grab some stones.
Grab some stones, dragoons.
Farm the stone, dragoon 3.
My dragoon 3.
You can still do it.
Farm harder.
Use your Lego hands.
Mom, my brother hit me.
Stop hitting each other!
Oh, I can't carry anymore.
materials okay guys you guys gotta stop hitting each other
all right you guys were born together we are a family i love
you both equally you both share the same amount of love i
have for the both of you despite some failures on one of you
guys that's a lie oh beaumont here i go dang it can't do I
want to fly all through the sky.
The thing is, though, I'm not very good at it.
Won't someone teach me how to fly?
Um, I don't think it's possible.
Keep trying.
You can do it, be your mind.
I will.
Thanks.
If you meet any Digimon that could give some pointers,
please let me know.
Wait, do I need, like, a Digimon that can fly?
What's this?
Oh, I got fruit.
I need, like, a Digimon that can fly to help them.
Rassin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So far, this game has had pooping and picking boogers.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Why Pokemon was more successful.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Rassin.
I think, like, no, I just need you guys to know, Digimon
World 1 was so hardcore.
It was like a lot more brutal
Because like if they if they are if they need to use the
bathroom They will poop on the floor They'll do it and like
you do not have time You do not have time to take them to
the bathroom Got a second Made my day Oh I got yeah I got a
tantamount Yeah, he's gonna open up an item shop.
I got two now.
Okay, nice.
All right, you're hungry?
Oh, they poop on the floor here, too?
I knew like they poop on the floor, but they also like...
Okay, we're gonna feed you guys mushrooms.
Here you go.
Here's a mushroom for you.
All right, maybe I should give you guys...
Are you guys tired?
Are you guys still hungry?
Why are you still hungry?
Fine, I'll give you guys meat.
There you go.
Are you guys happier now?
There you go, see?
Okay, someone said I need to talk to a specific mod.
items there's a plant type Digimon in nine planes who want
some kind of material a bug type Digimon has been spotted in
the forest and there's Digimon need of a good meal in the
forest oh that's the one with the one that wants the green
mushrooms all right which one talked to Kodomon which one
was Koderonmon again is Kodomon okay no that's are you cook
no that's Tokomon what's Kodomon look
Are you Kodomon?
No, you're Poyomon.
I can't never remember.
Oh, I talked to everybody by Kodomonon!
Sorry.
I don't remember what the babies look like.
I only remember, like, the rookies and the champions.
The baby names are, like, so hard to remember.
Let's see.
I need you to be the cat.
I just want you to be a cat.
It's off.
You need to sleep?
You're not tired yet, right, guys?
I don't think you guys are tired yet, so we can go outside
and explore a little bit longer.
We sleep when I see you be tired.
Not until you see the ZZZ.
Oh.
What would make him a cat?
Guys.
Toy Agumon is like, um, no, it's hopeless.
But I can still...
Dragon, Dragon 4, there's still potential in Dragon 4.
Dragon 3, you're hopeless.
But Dragon 4, you have potential still.
Serious.
It is wisdom.
Wait, what?
Wisdom for both?
I think they hit wisdom already, didn't they?
Yeah, oh no, okay, wisdom, okay.
Keep getting strong.
Mom, calm me.
No, wait, we can remake you.
You're not forever hopeless.
The moment...
You still have potential in your next life.
All right, we're gonna give you MP just because you have,
like, none of that.
Yay!
all right let's see we have oh you need a poop okay we got
to take you outside
it seems satisfied with their new strength you guys did it
don't worry dragon for it you're gonna be so smart guard mod
okay we don't care about guard mod all right go poop now go
poop oh i keep forgetting there's a bathroom like next to us
Speed?
What does Gatoma mean?
Uh...
I keep forgetting that.
Speed doesn't...
What does...
What does Gatoma need?
HP?
A bit of strength?
Don't need speed.
Okay.
Wisdom and MP.
Uh...
We'll just give you...
We'll give you a defense.
Uh, just because I don't know what else to do with you.
Dragon 3.
Yay, I've got a star!
Alright, nice.
Yeah!
Oh, now you want to sleep.
Alright, guys, we're gonna go sleep now.
Let's sleep.
Let's sleep outside.
We're gonna look at the stars tonight.
We're gonna sleep outside with all the other beings.
babies well good
night yay we recovered yeah we recovered everything all
right let's grab some meat guys yay all right feeding time
feeding time okay come over here drop guns it's time to eat
it's time to eat time to eat there you go
yay you're still hungry okay we're giving you mushrooms.
You ate too much, guys.
It's mushroom time.
You gotta eat your veggies.
You gotta balance it with veggies and meat.
I need you to be the ultimate, ultimate weight.
Oh, we can get more free stuff.
Alright, give me more free stuff.
Yay!
We got medicine!
Nice.
Alright, guys.
Let's go.
We need to... We need to go find more Digimon to bring back
into town.
And we have to make sure... I need you Digivob into a cat.
That's all I want.
Dragon 3, you can just like, I don't know, be there.
You can watch your brother Digivob into a cat.
You don't have to, you don't have to advance from Lego if
you don't want to.
Let's see.
We gotta go.
Where do I have to go?
Where are we?
We're like here to the forest path.
Ah, material spot.
Fishing spot.
Oh, we can like go talk to this one.
Life is pain as a Lego.
I love all dragoons equally.
You still have potential.
Dragoon 3.
Okay, this way.
Alright, this way.
Alright, I'm trying to figure out how to... Okay, we have
to... I want to know what this Digimon wants to come to my
town.
Alright, let's go.
God, the way you run.
Some fucking off-brand Lego shit right there.
I love all my Digimon equally.
Yes, I've come at a good time.
I need help with something.
I'm looking for fertilizer to help me make some tasty meat.
But I'm having a little trouble.
That's where you come from.
No problem.
Thanks, you're the best.
Bring me a cheerful apple, a Digi-stock, and a salty fruit.
When you can find them, got it?
Okay, salty fruit.
fruit.
I don't think I've ever seen a salty fruit before.
Does it admit that you hate us?
I don't!
I love Dragon 4.
I like how we go into this ring.
Nice.
Stronger power level.
That's good.
Oh my god.
See?
At least Dragon 4 hubs.
Wait a minute.
Come on, Dragon Role 4!
Make Mommy proud!
Go for it, go!
3, don't take your brother's spotlight, 3.
Let your brother, let your younger brother have the
spotlight, 2, 3.
4, you did it!
4!
Oh, that did amazing!
There are four systems and tamer skills And three to five
subsystems within these Switch between these systems Oh,
press A to look for subsystem Oh my god, this is a lot more
elaborate than I expected Getting a skill is not possible
until the skills Before that one have been inquired press a
on the skill panel to acquire the skills oh what the hell
what the fuck this is like so complicated what's this small
bonus during the bond boost oh it's treat type life type
reverse type boost parameter inheritance by one level oh i
would like that yeah uh if you're a team in a little region
you'll definitely be able to acquire all skills So learn the
ones you need.
I really want to learn this one.
What's the best one to have?
Um.
There's so many skill sets.
Yeah, I felt like the egg would be the best because...
Uh...
Um...
Walker type for free heal?
Where's the free heal?
Oh, here!
Heal while running is good.
Okay, we'll get that one next.
Um...
Let's see.
Have you unlocked it yet?
Okay, we still...
We have the bonds for it.
Uh, but other than that, we don't really have anything else.
What the fuck is Gargimon?
Good.
Okay, where do we need to go?
We gotta go this way.
Okay, I wanna go this way.
I think there might be...
We might be able to find the fruit here.
Defend order is good.
Defend...
Walker.
Okay, we'll get Walker.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's...
What's your name?
It's V-Mon.
The blockhead Togmon.
Even though my special move is so cool and strong, I'll
never go back there.
Hmm.
What's this?
Are you a human?
What are you doing in a place like this?
Oh, I see.
Is this your first time here?
Wait, there's like...
There's like fucking servers here.
Why are there servers in my desert?
this is server desert a place devoid of vegetation after
intense heat from old servers winters all the plants away oh
that's clever this is my space
the old break room called oasis has a vending machine and a
toilet Tower of New Type Server lies deep within.
Head out west.
A ways to reach wasteland.
Self-appeared lies another area called Logic Volcano.
But beware, the Digimon out there is stronger than the ones
you'll face in Nine Plains.
Are you coming home with us?
That...
Oh, wait.
Are you telling me this again?
Oh, don't they introduce this again?
Crypto Mighty killed the Planets.
Planets.
Oh, my.
What was that really intense game that's known to, like, be
used to test PCs?
Because I remember you guys wanted me to try it out because
the game was like, oh, no, you guys need to use the
bathroom.
Guys, I need to go back.
No!
Oh, my God.
I wanted to get to the bathroom.
Crisis.
Yeah, this is all the PCs that are trying to run Crisis
right now.
now.
Alright, keep going, keep going guys!
Dragoons, keep fighting!
What level are you guys anyway?
Oh no, oh no, your brother's always getting hurt!
You have to help him!
Your brother's always getting hurt, guys!
Help your brother!
Help him, Dragoons 3!
brother he needs help oh my god all right we gotta um we
gotta take you to the bathroom i'm heading there i'm heading
there guys give me a sec we're getting as fast as our little
feats can take us little featsies it's already over there i
don't know why i don't know why dragon three why don't you
like your younger brother.
You're older.
So you have the experience.
Teach him.
You gotta take care of him.
You guys have shared the same blood.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
I'm not gonna waste my porta potty.
I'm not, I'm not gonna waste, I would rather you poop on the
floor than use my porta potty.
I gotta, I gotta save up.
The same DigiBlood.
155.
Jesus.
Our bond is like half.
All right.
Let's go this way.
We got to run faster than these guys.
It's like these guys are so strong.
Oh my god, they're level three.
They're level three.
There's so many of them too.
I gotta run past all of them.
Alright.
I don't hate you guys.
You're all equal.
Oh my god.
No!
God damn it.
Oh god.
I need to use items.
Let's see.
Oh, I have a lot more.
Good.
I still have a lot more.
You don't even take any damage.
Dragon 3.
Alright.
Come on.
You guys got this.
Keep fighting.
I'm cheering you guys on.
Where to get... Oh, no.
Dragoon 4.
How could you miss?
4.
Dragoon 4, please.
Dragoon 3.
Help your little brother.
out he can't aim he doesn't have the hand eye coordination
he's trying his best
bro can't aim yay you did a drag on three not to describe
items return to town Wisdom chip.
Oh, wait.
I can, like, increase your...
I can increase you guys.
Oh, no.
I don't know what to throw away.
Ooh, this is going to be difficult.
Ooh.
What do I throw away?
Um... Get rid of the autopilot.
Do we not need that?
All right.
Discard.
All right, guys.
Apparently, I didn't even realize I had I that can increase
your stats so I don't have to train you guys anymore.
Alright, which one is it?
Which one do I need to give Dragon 4 for Gatomon?
What do I need?
Give all wisdom and HP.
Okay, wisdom.
Alright.
Oh, you both get it?
God, I didn't...
You're not supposed to be smarter.
Oh, just...
Okay, just you.
Okay, nice.
All right, I figured it out.
All right, MP as well.
Wisdom and MP.
Okay, here you go.
You deserve this.
Yay!
Don't worry, you deserve this.
Good job.
Good job, Dragon 4.
All right, nice.
All right.
No!
What did he come from?
Wait!
Keep your eyes open.
Where the fuck please what gets out of you aim I raised you
guys to be aimers I raised you guys to be able to aim I
don't understand
All right, come on come on dragon three Okay, I'm gonna use
this okay we should be able that should be like one hit for
him we did not register oh wait i used agitation no okay
there we go blizzard this should do it brother ain't that
smart even with all wholesome new me thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you all right nice okay now i can talk
please i just want to talk to him Hmm, it's no good.
I can't think of anything.
I may be weak, but I want to help people.
The problem is, my only skill is making this thread.
I'm confident in strength, but what can I use it for?
Uh, a fishing line!
Fishing line!
What a great idea!
Even I could make something like that.
Oh, this is where we get the fishing rod!
I don't have anything I can use as a fishing rod.
Can you help me find a stick?
Sure.
I wonder if I could be used as a rod.
Bring it here.
I'm counting on you.
How am I going to get a stick?
Oh god, oh god, leave me alone, keep me alone.
Please, leave me alone.
Please, please leave me alone.
Please, I need to go find a stick.
Wait, do I have enough items?
I should have enough items to feed him, right?
I need, like, five.
No, I only have two.
I didn't kill enough Digimon for more of the mushrooms.
Oh, no, oh no, oh, no, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, no, oh, no, I'm gonna run away.
let me grab this first nice yay oh and then dodged god i'm
gaming
okay i need to go back to give it the the food to the uh
give food to the one the other digimon I got more of the
chukes Alright here we go God I just want to evolve you into
Gatamon I can't believe it No please No Alright I missed the
stick No it's okay It's okay we have to go this way anyway
It's okay run run run No we have to go this way anyway
that's fine Where is he Where's the quest line for this Oh,
it's over there.
I went right in the wrong way.
It's over there.
Don't worry.
We're heading there.
Run, run, run.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We'll find another stick, guys.
We can always find it.
There's trees everywhere.
Surely one of them can be a stick.
All right.
Nice.
Here you go.
Hello.
Little Platin Lady.
Yes.
I got everything.
Yay!
Palmon joined the city!
Okay, we can find another stick.
There has to be another stick over there.
There's no way.
Something's here or something's there.
Really?
I don't think I see anything here.
Okay, we'll go through...
Is it this way?
No, it was like...
Oh my god, I'm already... How am I lost?
How am I...
Oh, it's this way.
Okay, I was gonna say, how am I?
How am I lost?
Is this only like this?
How did it caught up to me?
Oh my God, please leave me alone.
Leave us alone.
Okay.
I wish I could run away faster.
That's all I wish for.
All right, use your... Oh, I shouldn't have done that.
Oh no, oh no, no, your brother!
Oh no.
Live!
Here you go!
Why do you always let your brother die?
Why do you never use...
I keep forgetting how low HP he is!
Younger brother, he gotta hide.
Help your younger brother.
Help your younger brother!
Go!
No envy.
Why do you always run out of MP?
Oh my god.
Dragon 4, you did great.
Dragon 3, you were there.
Alright.
We got Greymon.
What's TF?
What the fuck is TF?
We got the TF part.
Okay.
And then, let's see.
I don't even know.
I hope we get there for, like, the other stuff.
Oh, training failure?
You failed?
How did you fail?
How did you fail training?
how the fuck
I didn't even let you guys poop on the when did you guys
poop on the floor
oh the mistakes oh oh I see I see you don't hit the icons
okay all right we're gonna Go back.
Okay, we're gonna give you guys food, actually.
I wanna make sure you guys have food.
Alright, I'm gonna give you guys...
I'm gonna give you guys regular meat.
And then...
Oh, wait, I just fed one of you guys.
Sorry.
You need food, too.
Give me...
Sorry.
I only fed one of you.
Don't worry.
Here you go.
I almost didn't feed you, too.
Alright, let's go back.
It's time to train.
It's time to train again.
Yay!
We got Palmon!
On Proof the Fields!
Alright, we gotta go and...
We gotta go and give you more training.
Come on, what are you gonna do?
Oh, they're gonna up, like, the amount of stuff there.
Alright.
Don't hold back.
What does Dragon 4 need?
I'll give you more MP, because you need more of that.
Um...
What does Dragon 4 need more of?
No, Dragon 4 has a lot of love.
Oh, for wisdom?
What are they now?
Partner.
Status.
Let's see.
He's only at 207.
Holy shit.
You need so much wisdom.
Yay!
We got the heart bonus!
Nice.
Okay.
100, 240.
Alright, more.
Alright.
Yay!
Plus 33.
Plus 7, plus 65.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, don't worry, I'll take you to the bathroom!
600 wisdom and 7,900...
Jeez!
Do you guys have... Are you guys too tired yet?
Or are you guys good?
Okay, I can still train you guys a little more.
Let's go!
Go.
Uh...
Go do your thing.
Yeah!
We got another bonus!
See, plus 33, plus 65.
Um...
Nice.
Alright.
I mean, I guess you're slow.
getting smarter.
Are you tired?
Dragon 4 wasn't tired.
How are you tired?
It's tears.
Yay!
We got another bonus!
Let's go!
I'm getting better at this.
Alright, 65, 33.
Okay, wisdom is almost there.
We're almost there for wisdom.
Oh, are you guys hungry?
Oh, Dragon 4, you're hungry.
Don't worry.
Mama's here to feed you.
Alright, here, have some meat.
Come on, eat up.
What are you doing?
You're not Dragon 4.
Here you go.
I guess you can have some meat as well.
All right, you're full.
Yay!
Can you remember to have both selected?
Oh, wait.
That's not what I want to do.
Are you ready?
All right, time for more training, guys.
It's training again.
Yeah, more bonus!
See, 65, 33.
All right, that's good.
I'm going to keep training you guys until you're done.
I'm going to be here until I get Gautam on.
Yeah!
Okay, plus 33, plus 65.
All right.
Why do you guys need a poop?
I'll take you.
Why do you guys go to the bathroom break?
And then...
And then you.
We got to feed you.
Hello!
All right.
Oh, Jesus.
How are you...
going through how are you still so unhappy how you i don't
understand how are you still unhappy i feed you stay focused
we're gonna keep trading until we get katomai until we get a
cat that's all i want
All right, you're gonna sleep in the gym
We're gonna sleep in the gym All right, time to eat It's
breakfast time All right, you guys gotta lose weight So I'm
gonna feed you guys mushrooms now You both need to lose
weight, guys I've been feeding you guys too much meat Okay,
an apple with a smile And Mickey, yeah, let's give you guys
an apple too You guys lose weight with apple HP recovered by
10.
Oh, it's just mixed like...
Holy shit, how did you get sad?
How did you hate me more?
You lost your sadness!
Wait, how did he lose his sad?
Wait, he hates me more now.
I don't understand.
Why does he hate me more?
What did I do?
What did I do to him?
Alright, 30, 60.
We're almost there.
We just need two more.
Alright, we're gonna go out to grab some food.
They seem satisfied with their new strength and training.
You did great, dragons!
You did great!
Uh, got Sorcerer Mons, got Guard Mons, Evolution.
Okay, we gotta grab some more meat, though.
eight nice we now ate meat i wonder if like oh yeah we got
store some stuff though store um we have way we're holding
way too much stuff uh i'll put seven and then we'll put all
the porta potty's uh shady thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you train will continue until happiness
increases all right you need more wisdom do i have enough
wisdom i don't remember if i like uh have no i don't only
have uh these oh i have mp oh wait no that restores all
right back to training you go guys we're not leaving until
we're not leaving until one of you guys turn into the cat
Where should we put where should we put dragon three guys?
Where where do we put dragon three?
Let's see Strength, all right, we'll put you in strength
Bonus Plus 28 plus 55 oh my Oh my god, we're almost there.
We need like 100 more.
Alright, bathroom break.
I got stronger than Spider.
Yeah!
We got our bonus!
928, you go.
We're so close.
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna keep going.
I like how all the bonuses are on the other Dragoon.
Yeah!
Oh my god, we're almost there.
Okay, I'll let you sleep.
You're not leaving this gym!
Your brother has to become a cat!
If it's the last thing I do!
Alright, keep going.
Oh, shit, you're hungry.
Oh, I forgot.
Sorry, I forgot to feed you guys.
Items.
Time to eat.
Alright.
And then, nice.
Okay.
Oh, shit, not you.
God damn, I keep forgetting to feed the other.
I keep forgetting to do the all button.
Okay, there we go.
Now I'll feed both of them.
And then...
Come on!
Come eat!
My favorite child!
If I have a favorite, but I don't...
Alright, back to the gym you go!
Yay!
Bonus!
Let's see.
Alright, that should be it, right?
I'm tired out.
Is that it?
Yes.
Rest.
Three finally smiled.
Oh, yep.
You guys did great.
Okay, I need MP now.
All right, go to the bathroom.
I need less weight.
Oh, my God.
All right, it's time to go on a diet, Dragon 4.
Dragon 4.
You gotta go to get on a diet for mommy.
We got to find some mushrooms.
We got to find some veggies.
Dragon one three.
You can eat as much as you want.
I don't really care.
But like Dragon four.
If you want the talent scouts to choose you and say you're
special because you're your mommy's special little Digimon,
you got to lose some weight.
All right.
We'll eat this food.
That's on.
This is a pattern telling you certain evos have weight
maximum.
Okay, we're gonna fucking need to find some mushrooms for
you We don't find you some vegetables You got find you some
vegetables so you can be a hot and Hot hot angel bond.
Wait, what was it?
What was the angel woman?
Oh, yeah, it was angel woman
Because after that you go
wait two of the level four holy shit oh my oh
no oh no um i'm trying no don't cry don't cry don't cry i
got i got the band-aid here you go oh thank god oh you're
not dead oh i thought you die I thought after I thought
after everything after all the time I spent on trying to get
you into a cat I thought I lost all the progress oh you're
still alive thank god oh thank god they're still alive oh my
god I thought they died holy shit anyway back training you
go it's mp time all right mp and then I guess you can do
strength all right back to the gym you go like all she cares
about is the dumb cat that's that's the king right
here we go eat your mushrooms you gotta lose weight you
gotta lose weight all right okay uh this one you get me You
can get me if you want.
Get it.
All right, nice.
All right, time to train.
Train again.
Yay!
Bonus!
Let's see.
We're almost there.
All right, and then more bonus.
Yeah!
God, I'm so good at this.
So good at this game.
Okay.
Body break.
Yay!
Alright, we're good to go.
Alright, you guys.
Are you guys happy with mommy?
Wait, we gotta put some stuff away.
Store.
I don't think we need any of the chips anymore.
We need more of the green mushrooms, though.
4,000 MP?
Wait, it needs 4,000?
I thought it was 3,000.
3,000.
7,000.
7,800 for a cat?
Alright, I need you to eat this disc.
I need...
Oh, no.
That's the restore.
God damn, I keep thinking that's the...
It's 7,800.
Back to the gym.
Back to...
We're not leaving the gym.
We're gonna train until you're a cat.
We're gonna...
Holy shit What do you mean A 7,800 What do you mean?
Oh shit It was Doesn't want to wake up Who doesn't want to
wake up Dragon 3 Bad dragon Listen to your team I want to
eat Holy shit Dragon 4 was like Listen to your tamer I wanna
eat
Holy shit Dragon 4 is it You know what it's okay if you
don't want it but but you you need this okay you need to eat
the mushroom okay because you need to lose weight you're
getting a little too flappy and no need to be a cat for
mommy all right here have some meat
all right it's time for you to lose weight more you're still
not the ideal way all right nice okay we gotta find plants
though let's go back and then we're gonna grab some let's
get some meat all right we gotta find some um we gotta find
some plants for you mp 7800 wisdom 600 jesus christ that's a
lot of wisdom
oh my god Anton thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you we need a fine plant so you can lose weight Gautamon
Gautamon is like skinny you're too you're too flabby right
now how the fuck do I find the mushrooms these mushrooms are
so hard to find We need to get MP.
I'm just going to battle wins.
You're right.
Maybe I should just get battle wins.
But I still need mushrooms, though.
I need five mushrooms.
Oh, fuck.
Where are the mushrooms?
Okay, guys.
We need to walk around until we get mushrooms.
Wait, what?
No!
You better evolve into a fucking cat!
Yes!
You're a cat!
Yeah!
Oh my god, look at you!
He's so cute!
Not you.
Look at you!
You ready?
I got the cat!
Oh my god!
You're mommy's favorite!
Look at you!
Cat.
Your mommy's favorite.
I got the cat!
He's so cute!
Look at him!
Let's pick this up.
What level is that?
Oh shit, level three?
We should be fine.
We should be fine with level three.
Oh my god.
Oh What the fuck I thought how strong is he?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, no, no, um restore 500 go get no, no Are
you okay?
Are you okay?
Dragon 4?
Dragon 4, are you okay?
I'm so sorry.
Mommy's sorry.
you okay right are you okay don't worry mommy's got you i
got the recovery disc for you guys are getting for both of
you what's okay mommy loves you dragon four here i'll kiss
your poopos dragon what are you doing dragon three dragon
three you were supposed to protect your brother You were
supposed to protect your younger brother, Dragon 3.
What were you doing?
Why would you let your older brother...
Why would you let your younger brother get hurt?
Okay, let's save.
Oh my god, look now you're a cat.
Look at that, Dragon 1.
Now you're a cat.
Oh my god, you're so cute.
You're so cute.
Look at what they can bite on.
He's with love.
Thank you for the super chat, Gio.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, let's see.
We gotta go.
Let's go to the weaker areas.
Why are we, why are we, like, so weak?
Like, where can we go?
I feel like we can't go anywhere because we're so weak.
Like, where can I live?
I feel like I'm just weak because you're still level 1.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, I got them on.
Dragon 4.
Show me what you got.
Fight this.
Fight the goblin.
I want to see how your strength is like.
Go!
Wait, maybe he's a little weak.
No, he's not weak.
Yeah!
Okay.
Lightning paws.
Show me the lightning paw.
I live at the gym.
Oh!
A thousand damage?
Wait, that's actually crazy.
Uh, alright.
You guys did great!
Good job, everybody!
Good job!
You got Taumons.
ability?
Okay, let's go grab this berry.
What's this?
Wait, what can you evolve into, Gatomon?
Okay, let's see.
Talmon.
Oh, no, that's that's... I want Angel Woman.
I want you to evolve into Angel Woman.
Alright, let's grab the mushrooms.
Nice.
Alright.
Maybe there's like less people.
Maybe like They're hard.
They're less hard here.
It's a power plant number two.
Maybe power plant number two.
Because I feel like everybody is so, like, overpowered.
Oh, God.
We gotta go.
We gotta go this way.
Oh, definitely not this way.
I saw level five.
Definitely not there.
Tableway?
Where the fuck do I go?
Why is everybody so strong?
Wait, it's two.
Okay, we're gonna have to use our items.
Uh, recovery.
Nice.
Alright.
So, and then use your metal claws.
Use it.
Go!
Punch him up!
Speed him up!
Come on, he's so low!
Yeah!
You go to the gym and live there forever But I don't want to
live in the gym
I'm trying to find a stick right now Why is it so hard to
find a stick?
I missed the gym Why is everybody so strong?
Oh, it's Dark Gobbleman!
Okay, we do not want to mess with them.
We don't...
Level 6.
Guys, we don't want to mess with them.
We don't want to mess with them.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that was scary.
I saw Level 6 Gobbleman.
We were so fucking dead.
We're so dead.
Okay, maybe there's a stick over there.
Maybe there's a stick over here.
Are there any sticks?
Are there any sticks here?
I fucked up.
That one time I like...
That was actually so fucked up.
I did not realize that was like the one time I found the
fucking elusive rare stick.
Back to the forest we go.
Come on, come on three your brother already leveled up you
were born first three your brother's already level up What's
stopping you from leveling up as well?
Come on If you want to win mommy's love you got him you got
to earn it
Look for the oh it's golden glowing patch.
Okay, it's gold.
It's gold Three is I love you enough.
You're supposed to make sure your brother's safe.
Where the fuck are the six?
All I get is wood.
I wish you could stop Digivolution.
Check the stats.
No, it's okay.
I still digivolve when he has to.
Wait, I got sick?
Oh, I just got it.
I didn't even notice.
Okay.
I want to make...
I want Gatamon to be a cat forever.
Look!
Look at Gatamon run!
Look at her go!
Oh my god, you're so cute!
You're so cute!
All that effort I spent...
And making you the cutest pay it off.
Oh, you need to eat.
Alright, gather around.
Now you can eat again.
Now, now you can both eat.
Wait, I want to make...
I want to feed both of you.
Why can't I feed both of you guys?
Oh, there you go.
Alright, now you can both eat me.
Alright, yay!
Hey, I'm going to eat.
You don't have to go on a diet anymore.
Dragoon 4.
Alright, nice.
Alright, we're gonna give him a stick.
I'm gonna run around.
Run away, run away, run away.
Oh, hey.
Yes!
I got you a stick!
Pesto!
Fishing rod complete.
Couldn't have done it.
Well, yeah!
Now I can fish!
Okay, we gotta go home now.
No!
Of course.
just literally yeah kick the plant kick the plant okay i
can't do anything keep going all right go fight go fight
okay there you go oh critical hit nice how did you miss yeah
we did it you guys did great i'm so proud of you Dragoon 4
3?
Alright, what are you going to become?
Oh my god, finally.
You're such a late bloomer.
I wonder what he is going to become, though.
A man.
No!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, we gotta run!
God!
We got nothing to be!
It was...
Oh my god!
It was meant to be!
We can't watch him die!
We can't give trauma!
Oh my god, we did it!
We saved Blizzard 5!
Oh my god, we actually saved Wizard Money, didn't die.
I'm so proud of you, Dragon 3.
Oh my god, I've always...
You were always a...
Great.
You were always a good dragon.
I actually got it!
I got the iconic duo!
I knew it!
My mistreatment of you, Dragon 3, was only so you can become
Wizard Monde.
It was...
I did it out of love, Wizard Monde.
Dragon 3, I did it out of love.
I needed you to become...
I needed you to harden yourself so you can become Wizard
Monde.
What do you love?
good oh my I'm so happy I got wizard one and got them on
we're canon now we're canon and we can fish it was digi
destiny exactly thank you for the magenta super blade thank
you thank you it was digi destiny guys okay we need to get
heroes for you wizard one you're fucked up right now all
that time doing strength training just to get a wizard look
it's because of my love that dragon 3 became who he was
supposed to be my love did this you guys doubted me but
there was a plan there was a whole plan all right let's go
oh I got yeah I got you're back I have good news made my day
hmm can you tell you what your partner's favorite fruit is
the city's prosperity is now for it there's It's a long way
to go.
I can't believe it!
Oh, we got recovery.
Nice.
We actually needed that.
I can't believe it.
We actually got...
The dynamic duo.
Uh, health runner.
Okay, we need that, actually.
Yeah, we need health runner.
What else do we need?
That's low.
I hate the study concept.
what is my what's the other one that we need mp runner life
type who's happy when wait what do we want then mp runner mp
runner oh here okay yeah we oh we don't have enough we don't
have enough though we gotta save up i can't believe it i i i
it's so funny I just see I can't believe I actually got them
Holy shit Alright Do I have enough HP recovery?
I don't remember if I was drawing If I Uh No I didn't Okay
we gotta buy some Uh Oh we're not Wait you're not 100% Oh
you are okay bye Autopilot recovery disc Alright buy one
extra.
Give HP and strength to Gato the Dragon 4.
HP strength.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, Gato Mon.
Get over here.
I gotta give you HP and strength.
Alright, here.
Get more heals.
Because Mommy loves you.
And more strength.
Because Mommy really loves you.
Alright.
And Dragon 3.
You're doing great.
Just don't die.
That's it.
Oh yeah, I was supposed to heal you.
Sorry.
Sorry, I need to take you back to the bed.
I forgot to heal you.
Give me a sec.
I gotta go back to heal you.
I forgot the one most important thing.
Wait, so how do they die?
Like, I...
Okay, my chat's dead too.
I think it has to be obvious.
It has to be an obvious issue, but I'll ask the chat coder
to see if it's like...
I'll ask the person who encoded the chat to see if they know
what's going on.
All right.
Uh...
You need a rest.
Yeah.
Sleep tight.
Yay!
Alright, let's go.
Hey guys, they're so strong now.
Three battles.
Oh my god, I literally...
Wait, if I lost that battle there, we would have died.
He actually would have died.
I literally avoided Canada event.
Wait, that's so funny.
I actually saved this life.
he was actually gonna die there that's actually so funny oh
my god holy shit that's so fun i can't believe i actually
avoided his cat in death holy shit i got an event avoided i
wanted to fish great you guys avoided the cannon event we
spider-man that shit you guys did amazing i still can't
believe we actually avoided avoided it where's the fishing i
was told i can fish here oh let's go fishing oh man press a
to fishing to try choosing okay normal there how do i fish
the fish comes the boy which which uh press the polar right
if you try to do this before fishing won't be interrupted
okay all right per se with the right timing where's the fish
oh yay i got digicarp because it's not a real fish oh i can
feed you guys all right level two Oh my god, Whiskey Mon is
so strong.
Come on, go in there.
Jesus Christ!
I told you!
Tough love works!
Holy shit!
Dragon 3, tough love works, Dragon 3.
Look at you, now you're so strong.
I know you're actually so fucking strong Jesus Christ what
the fuck happened you learned how to defend this brother oh
shit we got head home is there no food I have food oh no
what do you mean is there no food you think you think mama
would mistreat you guys like this Okay, I need to make sure
we were both being fed.
You don't like this?
That's okay.
That's okay if you don't like this.
Alright.
Let's see.
Time to eat.
Yay!
Alright, are you guys still hungry?
Come on!
Don't worry, I have more meat.
Alright, I like how only...
I like how only Dragon 4 is happy Dragon 3 is just edgy as
fuck
Something delicious is here?
What is?
What's hopping?
Did you guys hear that?
Is it Gatomon?
Is Gatomon hopping?
Is that your sound?
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Speaking of food, please feed us and kneel pets.
We're starving and dying of pox.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know what's funny?
I checked my inventory and so many people gifted me the
medicine to cure kneel pox.
Everybody was sending me the medicine to heal you guys.
And I I didn't accept it.
rejected the medicine.
Guys, I am trying to make sure you guys develop the right
antibodies to fight off Neopox, chat.
If I just give you the medicine, then you're just never
going to develop the antibodies that will require you to
fight it off.
You're just going to be like a fucking bubble boy.
You're going to be really living life of medieval medicines
there.
You're literally in the hotel.
She's a natural medicine, auntie.
No!
Okay, I'm gonna go, okay, I'm gonna, I'm gonna, okay, I'm
gonna buy you the medicine.
I'm gonna buy you the medicine.
I'm gonna buy you the medicine, guys.
Alright, let's go to the gym.
Okay, you need to...
You need more, I think, wisdom, right?
Alright, here we go.
No!
I failed it!
This is the first time I failed it!
Oh my god, this is actually the first time I've ever failed
it.
Alright, time to train more.
Uh, you need speed as well?
Okay.
Uh...
Alright.
Yeah!
All right, sleepy time.
Sleep in the gym.
Sleepy time.
Yeah.
Some good sleep.
All right, food time.
We're going to eat food outside.
Because mom doesn't have food anymore.
So she got to go to the soup kitchen.
Sorry to meat kitchen.
Yay!
It's meat kitchen time.
Meat that grows from the ground.
All right, let's see.
There you go.
You don't like that item?
It's okay.
It's okay to be picky.
You gotta have standards.
Yeah.
Anyway, eat it again.
Alright, nice.
So, like, when do they die?
How many days are they allowed to be alive?
I don't know if I want to see them die.
Like...
Oh, the H.
Oh, 14 days.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
14 days.
So, technically, they can never die.
I can't believe it, though.
Um, I can't believe I actually, I don't want to, did you
love them?
Okay.
I think we're, all right, I think we're calling here.
The fact that I saved Wizard mod.
I can't believe I saved.
I don't want those guys to digivolve.
They're perfect.
They're actually perfect.
They're perfect as they are.
So I'm going to call it here.
Oh my god.
That was really fun though.
I had a really fun time.
I still can't believe we got the we got the cat we we got
wizard mod and got them I was not expecting wizard mod at
all I'm gonna save game oh my god yeah I saved it I saved it
guys don't worry that's so funny though that managed to get
and then I saved wizard mod before he fucking got killed a
third time you could he actually it was This close.
It was actually this close that we could have got a Wizard
Mon death right after the Digivolution.
Um.
The Digibomb.
I can't believe it.
Um.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We actually witnessed the origin story of OG Gato Mon and
Wizard Mon right here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Half a second.
If we...
let it when we like hesitated for one more second wizard mom
would have been gone he would have actually been god oh my
god guys tough love made you so strong and now look at you
you're even stronger than gato man that was crazy you
literally like two-shot you two-shot people
um yeah i'm thinking of the super chat thank you thank you
rule one oh wait sorry i read that but thank you again um
yeah thank you for the super chat thank you thank you maybe
dragon 3 has only put in the same amount of work as the
appreciation you received thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you oh my god that's really fun though i had a
really fun time playing digimon world i'm i would i um i do
wish it was um it was more similar to the original digimon
world because much i don't know if it's because like i need
to travel more i feel like the original digimon world you'd
never you didn't really have to grant live in the gym that
much i feel like i'm feeling the original digimon world yeah
you didn't have to live in the gym um for that you can
actually explore much explore more wait you did you actually
did i don't remember i think it's because um was it
why my Digimon kept dying.
Oh, that makes more sense now because I didn't play the, I
was like way too young to be playing that game and so that's
why.
Okay, that makes a lot more sense now.
I was not training my Digimon in the gym.
I was just exploring the world.
I was triggering some like game events too because like if
you visit the beach at one point like a monster comes up the
other side of the island, and I remember stuff like that.
Oh, that's why my Digimon was so underpower.
Next order is pretty much a cakewalk compared to the
original.
Oh, okay.
I didn't realize, like, you were supposed to live in the
gym.
I literally was just exploring the world.
I thought the world building was really interesting.
I just remember the world, the world and Digimon world, the
original, was like really interesting.
And like, I loved exploring around the environment because I
couldn't read because it was all in Japanese.
But I loved like exploring the area and everything and like
looking at the different, uh, different Digimons, uh, around
the area.
Uh, Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tough love keeps retirement homes and business.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, um, but it's I had a good time playing Digimile World
with you guys.
And I might have given some of you guys, like, PTSD.
I might have given you guys some PTSD.
But I had a great time.
I hope you guys had a great time, too.
I hope you guys had a great time as well.
But in the end, you got...
became wizard mod in the end chat you became wizard mod
lali thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um but
um i always have a great time uh streaming for you guys um
i'm gonna head out because we do have another stream today
uh we do have good night dragons um and so i'm gonna spend
more of the time there uh there to with you guys so i'm
gonna call it here before i don't want to get too tired
before uh the second stream um but thank you everybody for
coming as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around to get that blood flowing if you stay up
for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys
next time everybody bye guys bye